Dracarys
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is my
Full House of the Dragon episode 6 video there's
a whole bunch of Easter eggs and references so
we'll break it all down if you're brand new to
the channel I'm doing videos for all the episodes
just like I did for the Game of Thrones series
be sure to subscribe to get them careful for
spoilers from the episode if you haven't seen
it yet we'll just start at the beginning and work
our way through shot by shot talking about Easter
eggs and WTF moments and there is a lot to talk
about so starting with the episode title it was
called the princess and the queen which is a
reference to the title of the original Dance
of the Dragons short story that George RR Martin
wrote chronicling the actual Dance of the dragons
like the actual Targaryen Civil War obviously
it doesn't officially begin here because when
we talk about the actual Dance of the dragons like
you're talking about actual dragon battles between
the different size the greens and the blacks
in the air like them both going at each other
literally and I don't think they're really gonna
set that off till either like the very end of this
season or the beginning of season two there were
a couple changes to the intro there were a couple
more lines of blood coming from Daemon as well
as alicent and rhaenyra's lines because of all
the children that have been born since the events
of the last episode it's been a full 10 years so
like a bunch of the kids are much older and new
kids are being born and this isn't even the end
of it there are other children like there's one
of alicent's children who has been born but wasn't
featured in this episode so we might see him in
future episodes or during season two so if you
thought there are a lot of Dragon Riders now just
wait till season two they also directly reference
that during the episode there are several moments
when they talk about all the different children
being Dragon seeds claiming dragons or already
having them the actual opening scene is of
renera in the childbirth of her third son Joffrey
Velaryon and it's meant to be a parallel for her
mother Aemma's death during the attempted birth of
her second son in the first episode that child was
named Baelon Targaryen obviously only survived
briefly after being born there were a lot of
different people having births in this episode
it was all meant to be a parallel for Aemma's
death in the events of that birth during episode
1. The Stark contrasts with renera is that the
whole thing with viserys and her mother is that
they couldn't have a healthy son but rhaenyra
has just given birth to three very healthy
sons and there'll be more children eventually
like much later in the timeline and if you think
about all of Alicent's children like nowadays
they're handing around male children like their
candy within the Targaryen family like you need
a son we got plenty of suns going around here
and just to give you an idea of how things have
deteriorated between Alicent and Rhaenyra in the
last 10 years obviously things have gotten way
worse between them there's like this stalemate
Cold War that's been going on between the two of
them they've just been getting worse and worse
and worse they have a whole sequence of her
demanding that ranera bring her the baby because
this entire episode and probably before this too
for a long time the way that viserys reacted to
it like I will not hear any more of this talk
like alicent has been talking his ear off for
the last several years ever since her first son
was born because alicent continually tries to get
people like runera other people around her even
Harwin Strong's father to admit that her sons are
bastards that they are the son of Harwin strong
when she greets Lord Caswell on the way and he's
like please ask me if you ever need any help she's
definitely gonna need his help pretty soon because
of the dance of the dragons like the realm will
basically split its allegiances you notice Kristen
Cole with the new haircut I mean it's 10 years
later but he doesn't really look that different
outside alicent's chambers he's basically become
her own personal Knight within the kingsguard
I'll talk about him in a second too because he
got really interesting when he was talking about
renera and her children oh how time has made him
so much more bitter you notice that alicent is
being measured for a new green dress because
basically that's her whole thing these last 10
years ever since the wedding she's been wearing
the green dress and when we talk about the dance
of the Dragons the names of the two different
sizes the realm calls them are the greens and
the blacks that's why later in the episode you
see all of alicent's children wearing green under
their armor in Oliver nera's children wearing red
and black it'll also be an easy way to tell them
apart when we actually start having dragon battles
in the sky like who's fighting who like well who's
wearing red and who's wearing green and when laner
is talking with renera and also when they're
talking with alicent throughout pretty much
every single conversation with every other person
when they're talking about the parentage of her
children there's always these weird Whispers and
looks people not answering questions like ranera
continually does not give direct answers but I
think pretty much throughout the episode they
want to imply that all the rumors about Harwin
strong being her son's father are true like they
are quote unquote the strong boys you also take
particular notice when alicent hears the name of
their new son Joffrey Velaryon which is the name
of his dead lover that died at the wedding she
actually makes a direct reference to that too ah
that doesn't sound like a Targaryen name does it
sound like a Velaryon name either alicent kind of
seemed like she's gone full-blown Crazy Town in
this episode like wow you have turned into Norman
Bates mother in this like you see aegon and he
seems kind of like he's a total crab bag but he's
a normal teenager for the most part he's as much
of an edgelord as you would expect a teenager to
be at that age in the royal family like a younger
version of Daemon it seems like alicent though
is slowly trying to poison him and poison his
brother and sister against rhaenyra's children
I'll explain the relationship between all the
different children too because viserys remarks on
that later like us and it's so great that they're
all training together they'll all be great friends
someday ooh the foreshadowing I also thought it
was kind of funny in like a really WTF kind of
way when Rainer is walking out of her Chambers
and just barely bats an eyelash looking around and
you see this trail of blood following her like ah
we know what's going on here here comes more after
birth that's how hardcore she is then we finally
get to see inside the actual Dragon pit and this
will probably become a thing later in the series
too like we'll go back to the dragon pit the whole
idea here is that rhaenyra's oldest child jacaerys
velaryon is claiming his Dragon Vermax that's who
this is it goes exactly the way it's supposed to
go like the dragon master here explains to him
in high valyrian notice that all the dragon
keepers speak in High Valyrian because that's
the language the dragons respond to is also part
of their traditions and they play this up like
a big prank against Aemond Targaryen alicent's
second son with viserys bringing him a new Dragon
the pink dread just making fun of him because he
hasn't claimed a dragon yet he will eventually but
they play it for a big thing during this episode
like he goes down to the dragon pit himself into
the dragon's Chambers and tries to claim dream
fire that's who this dragon is it actually becomes
Helaena's Dragon later in the future and there is
so much we can talk about with her character like
there's so many Easter eggs and foreshadowing that
they include in this brief scene and I love the
way that alicent reacts to all of her bugs like
she's just really entranced with it talking about
all these mysteries that they don't comprehend
yet when she says one day he'll have to close
an eye talking about aemond claiming a dragon
eventually he will claim a dragon but he's called
aim and one eye this is the older version of the
character that we've seen in the trailers so it
means that she basically has Dragon dreams like
danis the dreamer because right after her scene
they show you the model of ancient valyria and
it's a reference to the targaryens escaping the
Doom because danis the dreamer had a vision of
the Doom a dragon dream of the Doom of valyria
and that's why they left to come to Dragonstone
also them showing you the model of ancient valyria
right after talking about all of these Targaryen
children on both sides having their own dragons
is another reminder is that that's the way things
would have been in ancient valyria like all
these different families all the different
dragon lord houses would have had children with
a bunch of dragons thousands of dragons you also
notice that the model has gotten bigger like this
whole time all through the timeline viserys has
continued to get worse he's continued to work
on his model adding pieces to it so now they're
like little dragons all over these houses all the
different dragons on the buildings here are meant
to denote the different houses of the dragonlords
for instance one of the smaller dragons would be
believer in the black dread because he died when
he's about 200 years old that was long after the
doom of valyria so when visera said he comes
from before the doom he'd be one of the last
living things to remember ancient valyria before
the Doom he'd actually been pretty young pretty
small at that time then Alicent basically goes
full Karen for like the rest of the episode if she
wasn't already she definitely goes full Karen here
like crazy soccer mom on all of renera's children
blaming everything that happened to aemond on them
refusing to believe that it was aegon the second
viserys's helper that he dismisses is also named
Eddard which is another callback to Ned Stark on
the main show his real name was eddard we haven't
seen a whole lot of the Starks during the series
but the current lord of the house actually swore
fealty to rhaenyra in episode 1 and they were
at the tourney as well when things start getting
crazy with the dance of the dragons like in future
seasons they'll probably get a little bit more
involved but you have to feel for viserys during
this episode because it sounds like alicent has
been working on him with this whole rumor behind
rhaenyra's children for years and all he wants to
do is just work on his toy models play with his
little model of ancient valyria here like won't
you just leave him in peace then talking a little
bit about Criston Cole because it definitely
seems like he's on team alicent at this point he's
definitely Team Green the ironic thing in their
conversation though and a lot of you probably
picked up on this is that it's all about people
lacking honor but Kristen Cole throughout the
episode shows that he has absolutely no honor at
all which right after this they show you the scene
of aegon jerking it to the bells of the sept like
he's hanging out in a secret room this doesn't
seem like his regular room because the mattress
is on the floor like why would the prince put his
mattress on the floor in his regular room it is
just like some back room that he goes to to get
it on with the serving Maids because like later in
the episode when he's kind of oogling them I think
that he's at the right age where he started to
get it on with the servants on the DL like oh yeah
he's definitely pulling a Daemon here sowing his
Wild Oats all over the place and it's meant to be
a parallel for what rhaenyra is doing and alicent
being upset at renera for sleeping around but she
doesn't really care that aegon her son is sleeping
around and the interesting thing here is at least
at this point in the timeline he doesn't really
care that much about the succession he doesn't
care that we're near his son jacaris might become
king like oh okay that's great I won't challenge
him it won't be a big deal don't worry about
it and the reason why alicent goes full-blown
Crazy Town like full-on Karen like she grabs him
and starts shaking him a little bit like almost
strangling him I think what they're implying
here is that alicent really does think that
rhaenyra would actually have her sons killed
should she ascend the iron throne even though
ranera probably doesn't have any thought of that
at all in most of alicent's fears are unfounded
like she is full-blown crazy so I think what's
slowly happening here is that she's poisoning
aegon II against rhaenyra's children like the way
that viserys talks about them training together
becoming long time friends fostering this good
relationship between them as they get older
everything that alicent is doing works against
that even though they do duke it out pretty hard
in the yard but that's not because they hate
each other I think that's just because aegon
for instance really likes the thrill of battle and
just gets a little too into it then we finally see
rhaenyra with the older version of Laena Velaryon
at their house in pentos that they've been staying
at flying on their dragons character's and now
finally revealing vegar that she claimed when
she was about 15 years old she says the whole idea
with vegar is that she is a she dragon and she is
now the oldest biggest dragon the dragons just get
bigger as they get older this is like a size chart
to give you an idea for how much bigger vegar
is than the other dragons that everyone's riding
right now and also how much bigger balerian the
black dread was than vegar at their banquet you
notice that they're serving crab that's a call
back to crab feeder in the war of the stepsons
because they reference it later in the episode
like there's a new war brewing with the triarchy
down in the stepstones and now potentially Dorne
and house Martel this new Prince character is
the prince of pentos it's not an area that was
controlled by the triarchy so like it's a separate
force and he's trying to align them with pentos
and help them in the coming war that they think
will eventually spill into the rest of essos this
will also remind you that illyrio will eventually
live in pentos and he fosters Daenerys and her
brother viserys in Exile along with a Targaryen
restoration plan that he started with Varys the
whole idea is that he's kind of been living in
Exile away from Westeros these last 10 years
when they make a reference to marrying their
daughters off to people in pentos that's also
foreshadowing for the future like eventually
they will be betrothed to people I don't want
to get too far ahead of the story though they'll
probably reference that in next week's episode
or maybe the episode after that Daemon now has
twin daughters with Lena their names are Baela
and Rhaena they explain a little bit about them
in the episode but we might see older versions of
them later in the timeline just because eventually
we're going to have so many Dragon Riders flying
around on their dragons really cool history deep
cut too when the prince of pentos references
aegon the Conqueror helping his ancestors fight
off Atlantis during the century of blood that was
the period of civil unrest and warring that took
place in the East after the Doom of valyria with
like all the remaining Empires that were left over
fighting it out over ancient valyria's territory
the whole thing that's going on with Daemon in
Exile though is that he's just meant to be kind
of spinning his wheels not really sure what he's
supposed to do with him himself he talks about
ancient valyria being dead belena also says he
spends all of his time not going into pentos into
the actual city but staying in the library reading
about the dead dragonlords of old valyria if they
do a prequel series on aegon's Conquest they would
probably do the century of blood during that there
are a couple references to Corlys Velaryon and
driftmark during the episode he is obviously still
very active during this period but he hasn't been
master of chips he never came back to the small
Council the older version of laner explains in the
episode obviously a recast actor that his father
has been dealing with the triarchy forces that are
now causing more problems down in the stepstones
this past couple of years but it hasn't spilled
up into actual full-blown War yet you also see
Daemon giving High Valyrian lessons to one of
his daughters Bella but his other daughter Reina
who hasn't claimed a dragon yet or doesn't have a
dragon yet claims that he ignores her it might be
because she doesn't have a dragon yet because he's
seen very attentive to his other daughter baela
who does have a dragon bayla's dragon is named
Moondancer and Rhaen's dragon is eventually named
morning we'll also I eventually meet lucerys'
dragon as well when she tells Daemon she wants to
die a dragon rider's death that's also a reference
to her death later in the episode it's also one of
the many references in the episode to the actual
Dance of the Dragons when many of the Dragon
Riders die on Dragon back when she says to Dragon
Rider's death she's talking about dying in battle
while flying on her Dragon then we have that
actual scene in the yard with them all fighting
it out and you really get to see how Criston Cole
does despise rhaenyra's children like he is as
rough and callous with them as possible just kind
of throwing them all around ignoring them as much
as possible but like I said they do want to show
you that Alicent's sons don't hate rhaenyra's sons
yet even though they were all clowning on Aemond
so Aemond kind of doesn't like them right now but
that's because he was getting clowned on and like
I said they have alicent's children wearing green
denoting the side of the greens in the dance of
the dragons and rinero is wearing red and black
denoting the blacks then things start up between
Harwin strong and Criston Cole like rhaenyra's
old lover versus rhaenyra's new lover Criston Cole
very clearly trying to bait him into a fight just
trying to do everything he could except come right
out and say it in front of viserys you also notice
the drink that viserys is swelling now that's milk
of the poppy or has a little bit of milk in the
poppy in it so his illnesses progress so much
that he's become so weak and he's sort of in this
constant state of pain we also find out rhaenyra's
secret passageway that she learned about takes her
directly to harwin's strong's chambers explaining
how they could continue their relationship for
these past 10 years clearly his father knows all
about the rumors that have been going on and he's
kind of been ignoring it for these last several
years but just recently things have bubbled over
it's gotten so worse they can't ignore it anymore
so he tries to put a kibosh on some of the rumors
by having him sent back to harrenhal and probably
one of the biggest surprises of the episode I'll
talk about this a little bit more later in the
video when we get to that part of the episode is
the idea that larys strong like he's part of their
family killed them why would he go against their
family unless he has like a very poisonous type
of Tyrion relationship with his family but even
Tyrion cared about his brother like he had a good
relationship with him renera tries to get real
with Laenor Velaryon and they kind of talk about
their history together like for the past 10 years
I've been doing everything you've asked me to
do laner feels like he's kind of been suffocated
here forced to live in the red keep when he really
wants to go out and have fun and battle like ah
thankfully a battle is coming in the stepstones
can't wait to get out there and have some action
his new lover is Carl Qorey and even though they
obviously take off for Dragonstone at the end
of the episode rhaenyra is nice enough to say
bring him we're going to need all the swords we
can get which is another reference to the dance
of the dragons like they are definitely going to
need a whole lot of people supporting them there
was also another funny Easter egg for the Game of
Thrones series too when later starts joking about
the tairoshi general who dies his beard purple
that's a reference to the book version of Dario
naharas in the books he actually had a purple
beard purple hair he looked like this when laner
makes the reference about the coming storm that's
a reference back to what his father told viserys
about the coming storm renera also references
it again to him at the end of the episode which
is another reference to the actual Dance of the
dragons like the dance of the Dragons itself the
Civil War is the coming storm then we get a really
cool scene with Lena explaining dragons and dragon
bonding to her daughter Reina referencing seeing
how she claimed vegar when she was 15 years old
I was kind of bummed out that they cut this from
previous episodes because apparently they actually
filmed scenes of her like the younger version of
her with vegar that's why in the first couple of
episodes they had all those scenes of her asking
about vhagar in other scenes with other people
referencing vegar when she says there's many
different ways to claim a dragon there were like
two main ways one you actually have to dragon egg
like Daenerys did for instance once born to you at
the beginning of the episode jakaris and luceris
also get ready to put a dragon egg in Joffrey
Velaryon's crib which is part of their customs
hoping that in seven to ten years that dragon egg
will hatch and become Joffrey's new dragon rhaena
is trying to do the same thing in this episode she
was even singing to the egg in the fire here and
that's also what happened with rhaenyra's older
children too both of them had dragon eggs put
in their cribs alicent wanting to out the rumor
was hoping that they wouldn't hatch but both of
their eggs wound up hatching so Vermax is the egg
that was put in jakaris's crib when he was a baby
the other way to get a dragon though is to claim
one who was somebody else's Dragon Rider but that
person has died I don't want to get too far ahead
of the story but we'll actually see that happening
with other characters like there are characters
who don't have dragons in this episode who will
eventually claim someone else's Dragon who died
previously that's also a reference back to viserys
when he was younger because he was Balerion the
black dreads rider. Balerion lived for so long he
had many different Dragon Riders when she goes to
talk with Daemon also thought it was funny that
he also makes a joke about rhaenyra's newest child
Joffrey does he bear a striking resemblance to the
commander of the city watch they're just meant to
show you that even this far away 10 years on the
rumor about the father of her children has been a
thing the strong boys has been a thing in court
and around the realm for the past 10 years like
this whole time has been kind of this Open Secret
when they're meeting with the small Council though
they talk about the conflict in the riverlands
involving the tullys that's another reference
to the main series ah the Tullis can deal with
Tully problems themselves when renera mentions
the brackens in the blackwoods fight that's
a call back to the feud that they had at her
betrothal meetings at Storm's end when one killed
the other they keep referencing the come war on
the stepstones of the triarchy this continued Feud
with Martel and Dorne the whole idea is that this
period in history Doran has not become part of the
Seven Kingdoms yet it's not till way later in the
timeline that a future Targaryen King finishes
that and they become part of the Seven Kingdoms
it won't happen during the events of this show
though like it's way later in the timeline and
the whole thing with rhaenyra trying to make good
with alicent suggesting the marriage between her
daughter Helaena and jacaerys offering to end
the feud giving amen dragon eggs if syrax sires
another clutch it's just meant to show you how
much enmity there is between both of those people
like how crazy alicent has gotten like absolutely
not never no no no you have to feel for viserys
too because he seems so happy at this thought
like oh my God this is the greatest thing that
anyone has ever suggested to me we need to do this
right now and alicent's response is basically to
tell him oh you can do it over my cold dead body
we see alicent's meeting with Laris strong and
it seems like he's kind of been her unofficial
master of Whispers varic style for the past 10
years a little bit of Littlefinger in him too 2.
he's not quite as chaotic but the whole thing here
is that he basically has the rest of his family
killed why would he do that unless he has like
a terrible relationship with them it feels like
there's a bunch of missing backstory that maybe
they wrote and didn't film or that they filmed and
turned in deleted scenes this just explains why
his relationship with his family is so bad that
he would do that but after he has them killed
he basically blackmails alicent like oh I'm sure
I am sure you will reward me when the time comes
what he's referencing to is that when aegon ii
would potentially take the Iron Throne because
that's what he's trying to help her do to help
the greens win the dance of the Dragons Alison
also admits that she wants her father back so bad
she doesn't care that he'd be just as shady as the
current hand of the king Lionel strong she just
wants somebody in King's Landing who will listen
to her and support her the people in the black
cells that he winds up using to do this job are
basically just common criminals who were sentenced
to death to begin with the reason why he has their
tongues cut out is so that they can't inform on
what he asked them to do after the fact if they're
caught and as part of that storyline we get a
bunch much more exteriors repair and Hall way
more upgraded CG versions that are much more book
accurate than we saw during the original series
we saw the inside of Herron Hall during episode
1 in the flashback to the great council 101 AC
it is massive Larry strong also gives alicent a
really cool history lesson about the origin of the
harrenhal castle too and this is a Big callback
to aegon's Conquest like there are a couple
references to aegon the Conqueror in the episode
The Harren Hall Castle was created by Harrenhall
as a monument to his greatness it was like this
big monument to hubris basically it took many
many many years to complete and the day that it
was completed was the same day that aegon started
the war of Conquest making landfall in King's
Landing what wound up happening is the aegon
the Conqueror flew balerion in the black dread to
the harrenhal castle melted most of it with Blair
and the black dreads dragon fire the reason why
they think the castle is cursed is because after
that pretty much anybody who eventually became
lord of harrenhall or was given the castle died
a horrific death under really weird circumstances
in that continues into the present day of the main
Game of Thrones series much later in the timeline
too like it's still a thing the people that hold
it still wind up dying really mysterious really
tragic deaths so Harwin strong and Lyonel Strong's
death in the episode was meant to be a callback
to that as well the curse of Harrenhal then R.I.P
Laena we don't really get to spend that much
time with the older version of her she has vegar
basically kill her with a sad dracarus it sounds
like vegar actually understands the context of
what's Happening too like vegar refuses to do it
right away she waits a second then gives her this
long stare and kind of whines in this really sad
Dragon way you have to imagine that Veigar being
a female dragon has had many many many clutches of
dragon eggs over the years and even though Daemon
has been super shady the last couple of episodes
it does seem like he is sad to see her go like he
didn't want her to die but he has a scene almost
exactly like viserys had in episode one when he's
asked to choose whether or not to try the cesarean
you also notice at the end of the episode too when
jacaerys asked for near if Harwin Strong really
is his father she doesn't give him a direct answer
like she kind of avoids the question and like
I said I think throughout the episode like all
the references all the foreshadowing like all
the looks and the stairs that they give the way
the characters react to things it's meant to
be true they are the strong boys but it was a
great episode it is cool seeing all the older
actors I'll be interested to see how far they
take the plot during season one especially up to
the actual War of the dance of the Dragons if you
spotted any of the big Easter eggs and references
in the episode that I didn't mention in the video
just write them below in the comments my episode
7 trailer video will post next in my full episode
7 video we'll post next week after they release
it everyone click here for that episode 7 trailer
I'll update the link as soon as I post it and
click here for all my other house of the dragon
videos thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!